how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
marvel and
everything in the marvel cinematic
universe today we'll be talking about
the
eternals and in a very cool turn of
events we have
a plot leak for the eternals in which
parts of it are being
proven to be true one by one different
plot points of this plot leak have been
proved true
leading us to believe that this plot
leak for the eternals could be
very very legitimate since some plot
points of it have been proven true
and the best part is is that it's the
actors who are proving some of these
plot points to be true themselves
via interviews and podcasts so this plot
leak seems to be very legitimate we're
going to go over it so if you're trying
to avoid
any and all spoilers for the film you
should click away now but if you're
still with me and you love
leaks be sure to hit that subscribe
button so you can stay up to date on
everything in the mcu and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a deadpool
funko pop i'll be picking a winner on
monday so in this plot leak we get a lot
of information about the plot but we
also get
specific information about specific
characters and again a lot of this has
been proven true which we'll go over
but it actually tells us something very
specific about dane
whitman aka the black knight so let's go
over this plot league and talk about
everything that's been proven true it
starts off the eternals are a group of
super-powered immortal
alien warriors created by the cosmic
engineers known as
celestials and they were sent to earth
to protect humankind from
the deviants monstrous creatures also
created by the celestials that have gone
rogue so right now that's the basic
story of the eternals they're created by
the celestial gods and are essentially
immortal the deviants are their
counterparts who they've been at war
with for a very long time
and we've actually kind of seen a
deviant in the mcu thanos is actually an
eternal but he was born with a deviant
gene which is why he looks all purple
and weird
it goes on to say the eternals arrived
on earth in ancient times and lived
among humans throughout the centuries
always keeping their true nature a
secret
cersei who is going to be played by
jimmy chan is the eternal
spy and has psychic powers her mission
is to protect their secret but she
enjoys living among humans and wishes
her family could reveal their existence
to the world
now this is typical cersei as well in
the comics she loves the humans
and is kind of a rebel a wild card and
she doesn't really take too well to
rules which leads us to the next part of
this leak
dane whitman played by kit harington is
an archaeologist who learns about the
eternals
ceresi is sent to erase his memories but
they instead
fall in love leaving cersei divided
between whitman
and her family now this is straight from
the comics as well cersei and black
knight have a relationship together
although it's not that great
it's pretty chaotic and eventually
cersei kind of has somewhat of a mental
breakdown so the other eternals kind of
forced them to be together
so black knight could be her stability
but of course like in any of those
situations it doesn't work out and
eventually they break up
ajak who is going to be played by salma
hayek is the leader of the eternals and
has healing powers
she regards the eternals as her family
particularly because they are not
allowed to have children of their own
icarus played by richard madden is the
mightiest of the eternals and can
manipulate cosmic energy
he is loyal and protective of his family
and fiercely devoted to their mission
fina played by angelina jolie is the
deadliest of the eternals and has
superhuman reflexes
she is brash rebellious and prone to
breaking the rules and carries a great
secret
now if this plot leak does end up being
true then this secret is something that
we're all going to be very curious about
i personally think that if she does have
a big secret it is most likely a child
this leak says that the eternals aren't
allowed to have kids so perhaps she does
end up having a child
and has to keep it a secret from the
eternals and the celestials if this is
true then the child is definitely going
to be somebody
very important in the mcu it could even
be thanos his parents are
eternals and who knows how marvel's
going to change up the history of the
eternals in the mcu
giglamesh who is played by don lee is
the strongest of the eternals and has
superhuman strength
and endurance he's sensitive and
humorous despite his massive size and
cares deeply about the other eternals
makari who is going to be played by
lauren ridloft is the eternals as scout
and has superhuman speed
her function is to travel the world
storing knowledge about the humans and
the planet
she is deaf and mute and communicates
through sign language
sprite who is going to be played by leah
mchugh is the eternal zest storyteller
and can create
illusions despite being permanently
trapped in the body of a child
she maintains an upbeat demeanor druid
played by barry keagan is the most
dangerous of the eternals and can
control people's minds particularly
their fears
unlike the others he despises humans and
has his own plans
the movie will span thousands of years
and explore how the eternals influence
the history of the mcu before arriving
in modern times
when dane whitman discovers the tomb of
the space gods
which is capable of summoning the
celestials to earth to pass judgment on
humankind
the eternals and the deviants battle for
control of the tomb of the space gods
with whitman caught in the crossfire
unbeknownst to the eternals druid is
manipulating both sides to advance his
own agenda now here's where many of
these plot points get confirmed to be
true
for starters the tomb of the space gods
has already been confirmed we actually
have
leaked photos of the tomb of the space
gods from the set of the eternals
this also confirms another plot point
about this leak it says that this movie
is going
to span thousands of years and explore
how the eternals influenced
history well as you can see in these
photos they are in very ancient times
another thing that has been proven to be
true is that we have leaked photos of
dane whitman
and cersei in fact we've even seen
leaked photos of jimmy chan
and kit harrington kissing so that is
100 confirmed but here's where the big
reveals come in
way after this plot league came to
surface camille nanjiani went on
deadlines new hollywood podcast and he
actually confirmed a couple of things
that were true about this plot leak that
a lot of people were saying were fake
what the plot leak says about king go
who camil nanjiani is playing
is that he is the eternals wisecracking
fun-loving fighter
while the others have chosen to lead
unassuming lives on earth
kingo has used his abilities to become a
world famous
bollywood movie star now originally
people wrote this off
but while kamil nanjiani was on the
podcast he talked about what it took to
play his character and he described one
of his scenes
and he confirmed that the way his
character keeps his true
identity a secret is becoming one of the
world's biggest
bollywood stars and he said that he had
to perform an elaborate routine with
more than 50 professional dancers
so that's another part of this leak that
is confirmed but the plot leak also says
something about the character
fastos who is going to be played by
brian tyree henry
and they say that fastos is the eternals
is inventor
he is the most rational of the group and
was once very optimistic
but has since lost his faith in humanity
he is gay
now again after this interview came out
it has been revealed that his character
is indeed gay the actor has simon is
going to be playing a character in the
internals and in an interview with
new now next he revealed about his
character i'm married to the gay
superhero
fastos played by atlanta's brian tyree
henry and we represent a gay family and
have a child
confirming another point about this plot
leak so as you can see there are many
different parts of this plot leak that
have been proven true which lead us to
believe that the whole plot leak in
itself
is most likely true but what does that
mean for dane whitman kit harrington's
character
nowhere in this plot leak is there any
mention of black knight
and marvel actually hasn't really
confirmed that he is going to be playing
the black knight he's just confirmed to
be playing dane whitman but that doesn't
exactly mean that we're going to be
getting a lot of black knight in the
film if we even do get black knight
in fact kit harrington himself said that
he wasn't really a part of the main cast
but he is obviously going to play an
important role in the film
especially having a relationship with
cersei now what's interesting about this
is that in the comics dane whitman is
actually a physicist and he's the
descendant of sir piercy of scandia
a knight of the round table he ends up
taking up the mantle of his ancestor and
becomes the black knight however
in this leak it says he's an
archaeologist so we know that marvel's
going to switch it up even just a little
bit here
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
we won't see the black knight he could
just very well appear at the very end
of the movie and that would most likely
be the best time anyways as this leak
says that the eternals and the deviants
are going to battle at the end of the
movie for control over the tomb of the
space gods and whitman is caught in the
crossfire
he may actually be keeping a secret that
he is the black knight throughout the
entire film
and then at the end due to his
relationship with cersei he could reveal
that and come out as the black knight to
help the eternals battle the deviants
and this is most likely what is going to
happen because
marvel wouldn't have cast kitt
harrington to play a very minor role and
they wouldn't have dane whitman be in
the movie if he wasn't going to become
the black knight
now as i mentioned before if this leak
is true then athena angelina jolie's
character has a big
secret my bet is that she's either in a
relationship with somebody that she's
not supposed to be in a relationship
with or she has a kid
or both now in avengers infinity war
when thanos went to voromir red skull
said
thanos son of alars in the comics alars
is thanos's father and he's the leader
of the eternals and his mother is
suicide but since marvel doesn't exactly
stick true in their movies to exactly
what happened in the comics they could
change this and they can make it to
where athena is actually the mother of
thanos
because where were the eternals when
thanos was threatening the universe and
earth
their job is to protect earth but they
were nowhere to be found when thanos
came to earth
but kevin feige said that it's going to
be revealed what they were doing and he
even said that the eternals know about
the avengers but the avengers
don't know about the eternals perhaps it
has something to do with a relationship
between thanos and the eternals because
his parents are in fact eternals and
perhaps his mother
is thinna but let me know what you think
about this again a lot of this leak
has been proven true so the entire leak
is most likely true as well so
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like this video and subscribe if you
want to stay up to date on
everything happening in the mcu for live
updates you can follow me on twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof